By now, you've heard the bad news.
Those finks at Apple removed the headphone jack from the new iPhone 7.
Here's the good news.
They filled that space with precious, life-sustaining battery...
...and a bunch of other useful stuff, like a much better camera,...
...which we used to film this entire video.
Testing the 7 and 7 Plus for a week,...
...I found Apple has fixed some of what's long ailed the iPhone,...
...and that's reason enough to get over the headphone thing and upgrade.
Let me be clear.
The iPhone 7 is not the most advanced smartphone money can buy.
I'd say it's the best smartphone of 2015.
That's when Apple should have put it on sale instead of the iPhone 6s...
...that added frivolous stuff like a pressure sensitive screen.
Apple's still playing catch-up with the 6-month-old Samsung Galaxy S7.
While Samsung has moved on to incredible edgeless screens and virtual reality goggles,...
...this iPhone 7 looks, well, pretty much identical to the two-year-old iPhone 6,...
...aside from a new shiny, black finish that's an incredible fingerprint magnet.